[Music]
Diana thank you so much for being here
thank you for having me of course so to
start please tell me about what your
company parallel learning does so we
provide both software and services to
school districts around the country we
work specifically with their special
education department so in K through 12
districts you have general education and
then you have special education which is
about roughly 15% of students who
usually have a learning or thinking
difference uh Mental Health Challenge
and we basically staff School
psychologists speech therapists uh
special ed teachers a whole host of
different professionals who work
directly with students to make sure that
you know even this most complex students
are set up for success in the district
very cool so now if I'm an educator
logging onto your platform for the first
time can you walk me through like all
the options I would have yeah so we
actually have our own network of amazing
providers of all different backgrounds
who we actually place within School
District so typically it starts a step
before where schools come to us saying
you know we're in great need of speech
therapist or school psychologist we have
this many students who have an IEP or an
individualized education plan that says
that students need a specific service
required but due to teacher Staffing
crisis and so many other elements of
what's happened in the past couple of
years special education has been a
historically very hard area for school
districts to staff there's a lot of
turnover there's a lot of there's a lot
required of special education teachers
in terms of credentials needed many of
these are clinical professionals as well
and they're working in a very siloed
environment within the school so again
just a lot of turnover paired with what
we've seen with all teachers in general
over the past couple of years and so
with that um schools come to us usually
in need of of an actual service provider
and once they actually sign up with
parallel what they're giv as both uh
that actual service provider or a number
of providers who are able to work with
the students through their unique needs
and then the platform component is this
proprietary platform that we've built to
really help support all of the sessions
taking place so we've worked with the
largest Publishers of various different
curriculum for students with learning
and thinking challenges so we can ensure
that all of those students are working
through you know really the the best
possible um exercises and end curriculum
for them and that all of our providers
have instant access to all of that
curriculum as well as a lot of other
tooling actually that's frankly more
provider Centric to make it easier for
them to deliver these Services both
efficiently and really effectively to
drive the best possible outcomes for
students and then finally you know a lot
of tracking and and support for school
districts to keep track of you know
those students and how they're trending
towards their IEP goals um even just
who's shown up to classes and who hasn't
and so on so a lot of data for the
district side as well wow a lot of
different we have a lot of different
stakeholders that we're working with um
but you know with the ultimate goal of
obviously making sure that as many
students as possible are getting really
the services that they need to be
successful in life so I want to hear
about the why tell me about your
founding Story how this came about uh
well I'll start with I have dyslexia and
ADHD so I fall very squarely into the
population of students that we now work
with here at parallel and was lucky
enough to have access to a lot of
resources growing up my mom in
particular was very on top of things um
made sure that I really reaped the
benefits of early detection and early
intervention for my my challenges and
was diagnosed when I was 7 years old
which is a very unique story most kids
are years behind in core academic
subjects or struggling with with very
severe mental health challenges before
anyone really intervenes on their behalf
and so with that um was extremely
motivated by my own experience to kind
of recreate my reality at scale for more
students and was also um paired with you
know the start of the pandemic when so
many students you know schools were
struggling but general education online
uh nevertheless you know special ed
students were just simply not getting
served at all
and was you know extremely kind of
concerned to see the dire circumstances
and and that was kind of a ultimate
culmination for jumping into parallel um
my background is much more on the kind
of business finance side of things when
reviewers working on Wall Street prior
to starting parallel so um have been
really excited to partner with you know
some amazing clinicians in the space
operators Engineers to really bring
parallel to life how did it feel for you
going from Wall Street to then becoming
an entrepreneur it was a big
180 um I think I learned an amazing
skill set around kind of how to think
about businesses as a whole um but
ultimately like all of the operator side
of of things was learned and like I said
I think it's been a really amazing
opportunity for me to partner with you
know fantastic clinicians like our chief
clinical officer Dr Jordan Wright and
you know other folks that are are on our
team that come from all different
backgrounds and really learn from them
and be able to also hire just a Stellar
team of of folks that are just so good
at what they do and really bring I see
myself as like the facilitator bringing
everyone together so that we can really
ultimately you know push our mission
forward are there any competitors in
this space and if so how are you setting
yourself apart yeah it definitely um is
a kind of growing crowded space um there
are some incumbent players in this space
who have been around for almost decades
at this point doing virtual teletherapy
so this idea doing T therapy in schools
is certainly not new um this focus on
really kind of clinical excellence and
how to really Drive outcomes for the
schools that's a fairly new uh Focus
right and that's kind of when you ask
our biggest differentiation you know we
take the very strong stance of we want
to see students really improve as they
work with parallel and we want to be you
know the best partner as possible to
these School District so um Beyond just
saying that the students got served and
kind of checking the compliance box and
their I APS we want to actually see that
there is you know outright data showing
that students are are improving and a
lot of that comes from our focus on
using you know standardized curriculum
across our services and the platform you
know features that have really uh helped
our providers Drive the best um kind of
use of that curriculum and ultimately
you know the data kind of speaks for for
itself and that is kind of a
self-fulfilling cycle with these school
districts because you know of course
they do want to make sure that these
students are get getting seen and
checking the compliance box but every
educator goes into teaching for a reason
they really care about students and and
seeing them progress right so it's a
mission that we and our customers school
districts can get behind talk to me
about how many students and Educators
you serve and how that's grown over time
yeah um it's grown a lot very quickly um
so we started actually working with
school districts uh just over a year ago
so prior to that we were actually
serving families uh who are actually not
getting Serv within the school district
so we're looking for additional services
and that business was fantastic and
growing you know also very rapidly we
started selling to school districts in
kind of a happen stance way um and going
to schools who are referring a lot of
the students outside of the district the
schools very quickly or the districts
came to us and said you know we we
actually desperately need your services
as well and so that gave Rise um in
Spring of 2022 of when we started
deciding to work with school districts
directly um felt that we could make you
know an immense impact and obviously
really expand our footprint with schools
uh and students themselves uh by working
directly with districts so decided to
dive in that's actually now 100% of our
business um it's been an absolute you
know joy to work with districts you know
across the country we're in 15 states at
this point um serving thousands of
students per month uh doing both
psychological assessments speech
assessments mental health assessments
and then and also doing the kind of
ongoing uh services so things like
speech therapy um special ed teaching
and so on so uh really becoming this
kind of Full Stop provider um partner I
should say for school districts very
cool how do you think having a platform
like this you know back when you were
growing up would have changed your
experience yeah I think I'm lucky to say
and that I actually had access to a lot
of the kind of resources that we're now
providing via parallel um most students
do not and that is really where the
motivation came was to again really kind
of recreate my reality for more students
I was very lucky and that my my parents
went out of the way to make sure I had
the best resources I went to schools
where people were very well versed and
what it was like to be dyslexic um I
still had some tough points in school um
was not my my favorite point in my life
but it was just vastly different than
frankly what most students go through
today and so um yeah it was a big
motivation was to really kind of rethink
how to make this generally more
accessible and Equitable across United
States um yeah awesome tell me about
your fundraising Journey what's that
been like for you and how much have you
raised so far yeah um it's been a really
exciting Journey um it's amazing to see
how many institutional investors
ultimately support our mission um and
really want to see parallel grow
um I'm a solo founder so fundraising has
been something that has like fully
fallen on my plate um and something I
really enjoyed I think coming from
Finance World myself it's you know
exciting to be able to talk to
like-minded individuals about like why I
wanted to commit my whole life to
building parallel um and with that we've
gotten a lot of traction so we've now
raised um about 30 million in total some
from some of you know really the top
investors out there um from Tiger global
um obvious Ventures rethink uh impact
one just let a small round um in
parallel uh so we've been really lucky
to work with you know kind of investors
of all different backgrounds both from
the more impact Centric investors who
have you know more education more
Healthcare specific uh experience to the
kind of big growth funds um and really
see it from all sides so it's an amazing
opportunity to have you know everyone
around the table and everyone's been you
know highly supportive of awesome making
well what it is today so what would you
say has been the biggest challenge so
far in running your business and how did
you overcome that um let's see there's a
lot um I think just the kind of the
different variations of what it's like
to be a CEO have been I think
um difficult points to navigate
especially as especially as a first-time
founder uh firsttime CEO as I said you
know I don't come from of operation side
or I had never worked really really
truly inside of a startup I had actually
started a company while I was in college
but very different size and scale so I
think kind of that navigating from you
know when you're trying to find product
Market fit and you're so product focused
and you're like deep in the weeds with
all of the services and it's very
clearcut what takes from get point A to
point B and it's a frustrating time but
it's a very different time than than you
know say post kind of product Market fit
like you've raised your series a so on
and you're kind of like okay now I'm
dealing with a lot of like more kind of
strategic conversations I'm managing
employees I would say like if you make
me choose one like managing people I
think has been definitely the biggest
kind of growing moment for me um really
learning how to work with different
individuals and like Elevate their skill
set and get them to work with one
another to really push you know one
Mission forward I think it's become more
and more clear over time how to do that
but I'd say it was a really big learning
experience for me now that startup you
mentioned in college was that also
education yeah actually very random um
very very small scale um but was a
Tutoring company there was some like
software stuff we were working on as
well um was a really fun experience like
I grew up in San Francisco wanted
nothing to do with tech and startups and
then of course like day one on campus in
college I was like oh startups and like
entrepreneur club and all this stuff so
um yeah met a group of of other students
that were kind of working on this and so
it was a really fun uh experience again
like totally different size and scale
feels like funny to even talk about in
this context but um I think it was the
first time that obviously I did anything
in Ed Tech World um and it's like become
my thing which is not what I expected in
life but obviously something that I I
care deeply about um and also just an
amazing opportunity to kind of see like
what starting a company looks like yeah
obviously ended up in a slightly
different place today but it was I think
good experience going into it what made
you then want to just go to Wall Street
instead of sticking with the the
entrepreneur path um I feel like I
really I think I have like a pretty
traditional path like I take pretty
strong stance on I think it's really
good to get like the basic skills um and
as much as frankly like working in
Investment Banking was probably not for
me uh it helped me develop a lot of like
basic life skills and obviously also
understand businesses like I said to the
degree that I feel like I've chosen a
very kind of successful path for
parallel um but I think also just kind
of the rigidity of like showing up to
work and having bosses and like you know
all of that kind of thing like I I don't
think I would have done as well if I had
gone straight to the entrepreneur path
and I think a lot of people do like
immediately go into that path and Thrive
but I think for me it was really good to
kind of have some exposure to a bigger
Corporation and what it's like to you
know kind of be the Cog in the
wheel what would it take for you to sell
your company and is that your
goal well it's a loaded
question
um I don't have a great like offthe cuff
answer to that I think you know we
obviously think about exit opportunities
for parallel all the time like we are a
venture-backed company so we kind of
have to be thinking about that I
obviously you know talk at the board
level about it all the time and I think
for us at this exact point in time like
there's still so much to be done both
from like a mission perspective but also
from like there's so much more growth to
be had we're in a really unique position
it's not really a demand constrained
Market it's actually like if anything
the supply side and getting providers
who are really top quality and like
willing to come work with us and join
the parallel Community is frankly a
bigger hurdle for us right and so we've
been really working on innovative ways
to really grow that community and uh
yeah make parallel the kind of Ideal
place to work but I think there's just
so much more work to be done across the
organization and growth to be had before
we would really think about truly
selling the company I I think the short
answer is I would
only sell to the right stakeholder that
truly understands the mission component
of what we're doing because it is a
really Niche space it's not really like
the faint of heart to go work in school
districts and particularly not in
special education and um I would just I
would feel morally obligated to make
sure that if we were ever selling
parallel that we're bringing in you know
a new stakeholder that truly understands
you know what we're doing and why we're
doing it and I I think that's a unique
part that kind of binds everyone on the
parallel team together so important to
me that all of our investors and
potentially future stakeholders
understand that as well definitely if
you could go back in time and you could
give yourself one piece of advice the
day you started your company or the day
before you started your company what
would it be what a good question
um I got this advice later in my journey
but I think it's spot on and I I do wish
I knew it day one which is as a Founder
every everyone's going to be giving you
advice and I'm definitely somebody who
learns well by like seeing what everyone
else around me is doing and my like
coping mechanism when I don't know what
to do is like call other Founders and
I've probably dealt with it before um
but one of these other Founders actually
once told me they're like your job as
founder is you're going to get so much
information thrown at you opinions and
it is your job to basically decide what
20% of that is worth actually utilizing
and applying to your own business and
like throw out the other % and be
confident with that decision great
advice yeah and it it's true right like
I have so many people I mean I think
that was a quick reflection is every
business is different what works for one
business does not work for the next what
works in one industry does not work for
the next right um there's no like ideal
blueprint even yes if I like went and
started a second company probably could
do a lot of what I've done the last
three years in like half the time but um
I do think yeah being able to sift
through all of that advice that's being
given which is obviously super helpful
and be able to just choose like what you
want to go full steam ahead with is
really great advice I wish I had new day
one what's next for you and what
exciting things does parallel have in
the pipeline in 2024 yeah um a lot of
growth we're expanding uh we're planning
our expansion three more States in uh
January and then working on where we'll
expand coming the new school year so we
have kind of an awkward cycle because
we're on school year cycle as well very
true um so really excited to kind of put
all the pieces together again this was
our first full year actually selling to
school districts and working directly
with school districts so there's an
immense amount of feedback that we have
both from the schools and the students
that we work with as well as actually
the provider side that we're really
excited to be able to integrate in um
we've also really been investing in
building out our Tech Team and building
out our platform itself to better really
achieve those goals of both efficient
more efficient services and more
effective Services um that effective
piece I think there's just so much
opportunity especially actually as like
like the world progresses and we talk
about Ai and all of the exciting things
on the horizon there I think there's so
much opportunity to take uh really
developed curriculum that have Decades
of science behind them and figure out
even more um effective ways to actually
teach students so are you are you
thinking about AI as you go about has it
already are you using it already or
Howes we're not using it we're starting
to explore it I think from like a
workflow perspective it's obviously of
top of Mind how do we make you know take
some of the burden off of providers
right like a lot of uh the day-to-day
work that providers are doing is like
charting notes and stuff right so some
kind of obvious ways that I think a lot
of healthcare industry is kind of
looking at how do you you know improve
upon that workflow um but I think where
it gets kind of more exciting more
Innovative and where we're just barely
scratching the surface is I just think
in the realm of Education there's so
much opportunity for you know how you
can apply some of these these newer
Innovations to ultimately helping
students actually learn curriculum
better and more effectively and driving
better outcomes because that's obviously
what we're here doing yeah one last
question for you what would you like
your legacy to
be
um I think as you know a Founder in this
space like you have to say it's got a
mission element right like everyone that
works for parallel it's great that we're
a venture back company and we're growing
quickly and like the business success is
part of it but I think more than
anything that actually means that we've
done really a lot of good in the world
and that we've really helped change the
trajectory for students just like myself
that like frankly if I did not have
access to the resources that I did early
on I would not be sitting here today I
would not have the confidence for that I
would not have that basic skill set I
probably wouldn't have made it through
kind of basic
academic skills right so with that in
mind I think that's probably like the
biggest motivation is how do I really
you know hit the point where I feel like
we've helped as as many students as we
possibly can excellent well di thank you
so much for sharing your story with me
thank
[Music]
you